and joining us now dr. Anthony Fauci the
government's top official on infectious
diseases and dr. welcome back to Fox
News Sunday good to be with you Chris I
want to start with those videos that
Kristin Fisher just showed of those
thousands of people at airports
overnight rushing to beat the travel ban
waiting on line for hours you can see
them here in close proximity one assumes
coming back from Europe some of them
have the corona virus as an infectious
disease doctor are you troubled seeing
this yeah I mean we'd like to not see
crowds like that I mean I think what
people need to understand if you're an
American citizen if you are a family
member that you can get back you don't
need to rush back you'll be able to get
back but it's understandable how when
people see a trap a travel ban they
immediately want to hunker and get and
get home hopefully we don't have more of
that but I think we probably
unfortunately will see that and and is
that a problem in terms of the spread of
the decision obviously whenever you have
crowds I mean that's the thing we've
been talking about and that we really
want to implement is to have that kind
of social separation that is
countermanding that and hopefully that
people will understand you don't have to
rush back and to what degree is it on
the airports
to prevent that and not have those big
crowds of being waiting for our I don't
know Chris but the airport's can do
about that to try and encourage people
to tell them that if you are an American
citizen you will be able to get back
it's not going to be a problem you
testified before Congress this week and
you made I think what most people would
consider some pretty chilling comments
here they are bottom line it's going to
get worse the flu has a mortality of 0.1
percent sure this has a mortality of ten
times that what's different about this
virus what's different in how contagious
it is and how lethal it is well there I
would say three things Chris one it's
brand-new so we don't have any prior
experience about what it's going to do
what its dynamics are going to be number
two it spreads very easily there's no
doubt about that
it isn't like some of the other
outbreaks that we had that just didn't
adapt itself to spread among humans and
number three it's very serious
in the sense of morbidity mortality
particularly among and and then very
heavily weighted towards individuals who
are more susceptible the elderly and
those with underlying conditions and in
terms of contagiousness and lethality
worse than the flu well yes I mean it
just is and we've got to face that fact
we've got to be realistic I mean we've
got to realize and I said that at the
hearing that things are going to get
worse before they get better but the
kinds of things we're doing now will
hopefully mitigate that you know I
showed that that curve that but but
that's important because to think that
right now everything is going to be okay
if you don't do anything that's that's
absolutely incorrect we've got to really
always be ahead of the curve I mean I
was I say now and in a way that people
can understand I'd like to be the fact
that we're criticized for being
overreacted because when you're dealing
with a virus outbreak you are always
behind where you think you are so
therefore you've got to jump ahead and
stay ahead of the curve on Friday both
you and the president at one point
mentioned eight weeks now you weren't
saying it's all gonna be over in eight
weeks but are you suggesting that if we
do everything right that we could be on
the other side of the curve in eight
weeks the answer first of all we have to
say that people don't misunderstand we
are not sure what the duration is going
to be number one number two if you look
at what happened in China where they had
that peak and then they are coming down
there were only 11 new cases in China
they dominated the new cases just a few
months ago so if it started off in China
you know two or three months ago they
started coming down within a two-month
period so if you're talking about
reflecting what went on there it's gonna
be about that time that we hopefully in
the next couple of months are gonna see
the direction it's gonna go hopefully
what we're doing in a very aggressive
way of containment and
gation will be able to not only flatten
it in the sense of not as many cases but
also diminish the duration president
from announced a public-private
partnership on Friday and made it sound
like the serious testing around the
country will that we'll be seeing it
soon first there was this I want to
thank Google Google is helping to
develop a website it's going to be very
quickly done unlike websites of the past
but Google's sister company farily put
out a statement later that said this
test which according to to him and and
other officials first of all will let
you sort of check whether your symptoms
indicate you have it and to if if you do
seem to have it will tell you where you
can get testing in fact is just starting
and is just in a pilot program for the
Bay Area and that it's gonna take over
time they said for it to be applied
nationally and while the president made
it sound like math testing is going to
start very soon there are a lot of
experts who say that whether it's
staffing public health staffing or the
products or the chemicals needed for
math testing that we're way behind the
curve on that so I guess my question is
how soon can people across the country
expect mass drive through testing okay
so there are two issues here Chris
there's a website and when it's going to
be fully open versus the availability of
testing they really are somewhat
separate so put aside the website and
how it's going to be fully operational
the CEOs of the companies that we had at
the White House that the president met
with it's very clear that when I
specifically asked them when can we get
started
to start doing this where you can really
have availability in a much easier way
implementing not just saying that it's
out there they're telling us that that
will be starting up within the next week
or so that it's gonna go up now in the
reality there are gonna be people a week
from now
to say I try to get a test that I
couldn't get it but the totality of the
picture is gonna be infinitely better
than it was a few weeks ago I want to
talk to you about a few weeks ago
because there are continuing questions
about why other countries South Korea
may be the best example are testing
thousands of people a day and so far the
CDC says that it and state labs
total the whole crisis have tested
13,000 people here's how you and the
president answered questions about the
testing lag this week the idea of
anybody getting it easily the way people
in other country are doing it we're not
set up for that do I think we should be
yes but we're not no I don't take
responsibility at all because we were
given a a set of circumstances and we
were given rules regulations and
specifications from a different time the
president says the Obama administration
set up rules and regulations that made
it impossible to do testing you were in
the same position under the Obama
administration is that true is that what
stopped it you know Chris to be honest
with you I'm not sure what regulations
and when it was that they're talking
about I really mean that I mean I'm
trying to figure out what it is that
these things were in place that were
able to or inhibiting but one thing that
I do know now is that the the ability to
get a test had some regulatory and other
restrictions on it what the FDA now has
just gotten rid of I mean could have
done that well yeah they could have but
the fact is it wasn't so I tend to like
to instead of looking back look at where
we're going all right you talked about
slowing the virus down you talked a lot
and I've gotten very used to this now
you could either have a bump like this
of cases where you could make it maybe
the same total cases but it's a much
more gradual and slower and longer curve
I want to put up some numbers we have in
this country about 950 thousand hospital
beds
and about 45,000 beds in intensive care
units how worried are you that this
virus is gonna overwhelm hospitals not
just beds but ventilators we only have
160,000 ventilators and could we be in a
situation where you have to ration who
gets the bed who gets the ventilator
okay so let me put it in a way that it
doesn't get taken out of context when
people talk about modeling where
outbreaks are going the modeling is only
as good as the assumptions you put into
the model and what they do they have a
worst case scenario a best case scenario
and likely where it's gonna be if we
have a worst case scenario we've got to
admit it we could be overwhelmed all we
can have a worst case scenario I don't
think so
I hope not what are we doing simply to
not have that worst case scenario that's
when you get into the things that we're
doing we're preventing infections from
going in with some rather stringent
travel restrictions and we're doing
containment and mitigation from within
so at a worst case scenario anywhere in
the world no matter what country you are
you won't be prepared so our job is to
not let that worst-case scenario happen
and final question three countries now
in Europe Italy Spain and France are
basically in total lockdown people not
allowed out in Italy
I think calming pharmacies and grocery
stores are open you see people on the
balconies singing songs and banging pots
could that happen here either nationally
or in some regions and what about the
possibility that we might have to have
travel bans inside the country well a
couple of questions yes so let me take
one at a time yeah the idea of what's
going on in Europe is that they have
been they got into that escalation phase
so what they're doing now is playing
catch-up we feel that with rather
stringent mitigation and containment
without necessarily complete lockdown
we'd be able to prevent ourselves from
getting to where unfortunately Italy is
now with regard to domestic travel bans
we always talk about and consider
everything but I can tell you that has
not been
seriously considered doing travel bans
in the country would it might be some
time we always leave an open mind
dr. pouchy thank you thanks for coming
in an awful lot of people are relying
and what you have to say and of course
we'll be tracking what the president's
task force does this week thank you sir
thank you good to be with you Chris